- So you talk openly about your exes.
I often write about my situations
like that like in music
and it's very therapeutic for me.
Was it therapeutic for you?
- Your music has gotten
me through many a breakup
so thank you for that.
(audience cheering)
- Me too.
- So thank you.
You've helped all of us
And yeah, I do think that this was,
you know, just a cathartic situation
because so much is said out there
and sometimes there's
not a lot of context.
- Or clarity, yeah.
- Yeah and coming from
a place of, you know
of a healing place, like,
I am past those things,
I am healed, there's no anger there.
So it's nice to kind of,
you know, give context
and you know, tell a story
that I know a lot of people
have related to that, you
know, these things happen
- Yeah.
- and whether it, you know
and sometimes they're not
all great and you know,
Instagram and stuff, you
only see the good stuff.
- The filtered versions.
- So it's nice
to kind of, you know,
- Yeah.
- get into the real stuff
and explain how you go from there
to you know,
- Yeah.
- Getting back to the good part.
- Yeah, mo, absolutely.
It's nice too,
because everybody is
working through those same,
we're all under construction
so it's very relatable,
but I did hear this was pretty good.
So you sold your wedding ring
to help pay for your new house,
was that therapeutic 'cause
- Well.
- I love that.
- You know, Kelly.
- That's funny.
- I will say so when sometimes
life gives you lemons
sometimes you gotta add a little vodka.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- So
- Yeah, that's amazing.
- I was trying to, you know make the best
out of a situation.
- Yeah.
- So yeah, you know--
- I mean, what are you supposed to do,
keep wearing it like,
you know, I guess, yeah.
Yeah, I think that's amazing.
- Yeah.
- You did something good with the money.